in other news this morning supply chain
issues inflation they're putting a
strain on small business and ultimately
you we spoke to local business owners
about how they're handling these
difficulties certainly there's a lot of
them bianca holman joining us now with
that report bianca good morning to you
good morning so with prices here in the
u.s up eight percent you probably
noticed well because you're having to
pay for it so we're able to talk with
local businesses around the valley
various business owners about how
they're handling this inflation so
research from business.org says 89
percent of small business owners
increased their prices to counter
inflation another 64 say they were able
to acquire they were not able to acquire
products needed to meet customer demand
because of supply chain shortages we
spoke with business owners from various
industries about their experience here
in las vegas owner afuku burger says at
times they even had to barter with other
restaurants to make up for missing items
especially things like paper and plastic
goods a lot more people eating out and
doing to go orders while he's not had to
raise his prices other business owners
have
i don't want to be too reactionary and
panic and and make this you know pass on
the cost of the guest so i mean i'm
willing to struggle for a little bit
longer to see how long we're going to be
in a normal phase um as uh as a pandemic
you know starts to ease off it's really
really tough but then you know since
this is happening globally
and uh specifically in nevada in all
businesses they raised their prices so
people understood you know and we also
sending out the notification via e-blast
or email to all of our members that will
be increasing our pricing soon
and you just heard from leah
yulanti and she's had to raise her
prices she says they raised prices just
after the new year she says they've had
promos to help entice new customers and
get a help fit in people's budgets but
ultimately having to spike raise prices
in certain services and so coming up in
the next half hour we're going to talk
with business owners about the lift of
the mass mandate and how that's helping
to give business owners some relief as
they're seeing increase in business over
the past week bianca holman live local
now